this Brandy is a dronesy she continued
because you got to find somebody to
blame when bad people do things what you
gotta do is you gotta figure out a way
to blame the people you don't like and
of course that's always going to involve
Tucker Carlson and in this case there's
the famous Twitter account unsuspended
now Libs of tick tock Brandy explain
that when you hear that your reaction to
it and then kind of walk us through how
rhetoric online rhetoric from
politicians can ultimately trickle down
into real life and seeing examples of
what happened over the weekend if there
is a pipeline it starts from some
smaller accounts online like Libs of
tick tock it moves to the right-wing
blogosphere and then it ends up on
Tucker Carlson or it ends up out of a
right-wing politician's mouth and it's a
really dangerous cycle
bananas these people are so bananas so
for those of you that don't know how the
internet works people post all sorts of
things and then people start talking
about all sorts of things and sharing
all sorts of things and then yes
occasionally they do trickle up when
there's enough people talking about a
certain thing or enough people have
exposed a certain thing or shared video
of something then it might get to say a
Tucker Carlson and Tucker Carlson might
go boy that is awfully interesting the
libs of tick tock account by the way
they do not instigate hate they have
never as I have seen it is run by a
woman who has since been doxed by by
many quote-unquote journalists they know
she never says go hurt these people she
never I don't even think she says these
people are evil or anything to that
effect she basically reposts their posts
so all of these trans teachers and these
gender queer asexual penis vagina
teachers they go make their own videos
the penis vagina teachers that's in
seventh grade when I took Health that's
what they we called them uh
they put their own videos usually crying
in their cars uh talking about how
they're trying to indoctrinate these
kids they usually don't say the word
indoctrination but they say we're trying
to teach these kids about gender and
sexuality and fluidity and then they
post them on Tick Tock or wherever it
might be and then all she does is repost
them that's what she does so if anything
she's acting as a journalist oh here's a
person saying a certain something I'm
just showing people what it is okay so
that's just how it is but you see this
is another reason why they're so upset
by the Elon Musk thing because little
accounts share things and then it gets
to Big Tucker Carlson and we can't have
little people sharing the truth because
little people are the fertilizer for the
thing that grows and that's Tucker
Carlson